i didn't know you were good friends with
kim kardashian but they asked her to
host saturday night live and you wrote
her best joke for her which most people
didn't know i thought it was her best
joke oh thank you tell the joke you
wrote for kim kardashian okay well i'm
gonna butcher it it's been but i was
just trying to kind of put it into
perspective for her and i'm like you're
usually
you usually i don't know how many
followers she has but it's probably 300
million i'm like i think
what 10 million people watch snl like
this is a this is an intimate night for
you you know yeah and so that was it it
was just like i mean the joke was more
or less pointing out the fact that she
has 300 million followers and being on
snl was like kind of a come down when
you're thinking about it it's like doing
a fundraiser for like a friend that's
not going to raise that much money
so let me understand you'll sit home i
love snl and i would love to host again
i would never think you'd be friends
with kim kardashian because
because you're a comedian and i would
think you can make fun of it she laughs
at herself like that family is actually
really cool i mean she went after her
family in that monologue i mean she's an
amazing person like think about what
she's accomplished you know
and you will hang with her you in other
words this is a personal friend of yours
and you guys hang out and all that stuff
we don't we don't hang out like we've
hung out a couple times but
you know it's not like
we get coffee twice a week
and those mornings are for us for the
ladies no but we um
we are in you know we text all the time
and oh wow on and yeah
yeah and i actually don't remember how
it happened like i i don't know
oh actually yes i i remembered how it
happened i think
we we were both at the met ball
a couple years ago and
you know that you're not allowed to
bring anybody i mean i'm sure she can
she could bring you know
100 people she wanted i'm not allowed to
bring anybody so anyway get in the met
ball and uh and we were like kind of
alone like it was just
we just started talking like about
what's really going on with us and how
we're feeling about things and yeah we
just like yeah and i mean
when i threw myself in front of her
on the carpet her and kanye
at the time 100.
she i could feel in that moment and i'm
sure i was projecting but she wanted to
laugh you know she didn't know what to
do and
and was definitely following kanye's
lead but um
but i was like it made me think she's
funny
like that she
she was like knew like
i was just doing something ridiculous
and i almost did it again i was behind
her in line at the vanity fair party um
it was her and her sister kendall and i
we talked we said hi we gossiped about
the night and then
i was like saying to chris you know my
husband i'm like
should i go throw myself in front of her
and he's like no